an adorable robot cannibalizes his peers
babies are produced in questionable ways
an allegory for screen addiction from
one of the biggest media companies in
the world these are the things only
adults notice while watching wall-e
in retrospect it's clear that 2008 was a
simpler time it was only two years after
the documentary and inconvenient truth
began to really spread awareness of the
threat that global warming posed to the
planet and the more broadly sinister
blanket term climate change was hardly
in the news at all the ensuing years
have seen an increasing number of
record-setting temperatures at various
points all over the world with them has
come more frequent wildfires polar
vortexes unusually active hurricane
seasons and countless other disasters
that are all attributable to climate
change wally is almost quaint in
representing the harm that we've done to
the planet our small resolute waste
allocation load lifter earth class robot
has apparently spent centuries packing
refuse into cubes making for a
strikingly apt visual metaphor but even
though we aren't yet piling garbage so
high that it towers over skyscrapers
trash is indeed a big part of the real
climate crisis in reality landfills are
estimated to account for 10 percent of
greenhouse gas emissions by 2025 in
addition to causing a host of other
environmental issues the backdrop of
wall-e was already one of the most
chilling and relevant settings for any
kids movie when it came out and it only
becomes more terrifyingly relevant with
each passing year
even if you can summon the will to set
the reality of climate concerns aside
and just let wally cast its spell on you
the central premise is still almost
unbearably sad there's just no way to
look past the fact that wally is a small
robot whose sole purpose is to condense
waste into neatly stacked cubes he's
been laboring at this job for around 700
years on a deserted planet earth with
only a cockroach and a trailer full of
junk for company the opening scenes of
the movie are set to a jaunty show tune
and they manage to mind some humor out
of wally's confused reactions to
recognizable everyday objects but if you
actually stop and think about this
robot's existence it's a rather modeling
way for a film to begin fortunately
wally only takes us through one day in
the life of its impossibly lonely
protagonist before a mysterious rocket
lands and the real adventure begins but
for the first 10 minutes or so kids and
adults alike are invited to contemplate
solitude and futility in the bleakest
opening in pixar history
[Music]
not only does wally have a premise
that's both horrifically sad and
unnervingly relevant it's also largely
about two robots that only say a half a
dozen words or so between the two of
them when you think about it it's
amazing that audiences were able to
emotionally connect with the story at
all that they did is in large part
thanks to songs from the 1969 movie
musical hello dolly wally has managed to
find a vhs copy of this particular film
that improbably still works and repeated
clips of just two of its songs serve as
emotional shorthand at several different
points the peppy put on your sunday
clothes serves as the innovating ironic
choice to open the movie as we zoom in
on the polluted empty earth it then goes
on to be a theme song for both wally's
curiosity and optimism as well as a
rallying cry for his robot brethren
aboard the axiom spaceship meanwhile it
only takes a moment is the theme song
for wally and eve's romantic connection
there's even a scene set to lavien rose
by louis armstrong who also appeared in
hello dolly thanks to the contributions
of a classic musical alongside thomas
newman's subtle yet wonderful score
revisiting wally as an adult really
makes you consider how much music can
accomplish in a nearly wordless film
in the future presented in wali the
corporation by and large is
indistinguishable from the government
ceo shelby forthright played in a few
scenes by fred willard in live action
speaks from a podium in front of a blue
backdrop that looks a lot like the white
house it's implied that by and large is
solely responsible for operation cleanup
the plan to save earth while humanity is
off-world on luxury space cruise ships
it's something that initially seems
darkly ironic and silly but it has grim
and sinister implications that only get
more uncomfortable for those of us
who've aged through major recessions and
government misconduct over the years
because at b l space is the final
fun tier
you might think that disney who bought
pixar just a couple years before wally
was released wouldn't want to pull the
thread on how giant corporations with
government ties are leading us down a
ruinous environmental path of course
this was before disney went on to
acquire marvel studios lucasfilm and
20th century fox so it wasn't as on the
nose at the time as it is today still
it's more than a little ironic in
retrospect how the general theme of
wally seems to tell us to stop being
such consumers even though the movie is
a commercial product from one of the
biggest companies in human history
another thing that we may have already
forgotten about life in 2008 is that
screens weren't as omnipresent in our
lives as they are now most phones were
still of the flipped variety and plenty
of people still used blackberries
devices then weren't nearly as
entrancing as modern day smartphones
with their endless apps games and
constant demand on our attention netflix
had just barely introduced its streaming
service so youtube was the only real
video streaming option with only a
fraction of the content that it has
today in the years since streaming has
become ubiquitous and if we're not
careful about our screen time habits
then we'll find ourselves in an
existence that's basically a
planet-sized version of the axiom most
chillingly especially after the mass
shift to remote work during the covet-19
pandemic wall-e's human characters are
seen using a zoom-like interface in
their hoverchair displays to talk to
each other instead of just getting up
and having face-to-face interactions
meanwhile in the real world we've got
screens in our cars screens on our
appliances and screens on our wrist
watches devices are getting so smart
that it will be a great challenge for
modern humanity to remember that we're
on a planet and not a spaceship thus
wally serves as a helpful cautionary
tale to remind us that we can't
completely rely on this so-called smart
technology
my nephew bought me a smartphone for
chris if it's so smart why can't i get a
driver's license it's only through
wally's chaotic influence that we see
two humans on the axiom mary and john
start to interact with each other and
accidentally hold hands the novelty of
it shines on their delighted bashful
faces for adult viewers however an
unsettling thought comes crashing in to
undercut it if that's where people are
in the future in terms of potential
relationships then how have new babies
been born on the axiom for the last 700
years we distinctly see a group of
toddlers being taught by robots in a
daycare earlier in the film but
considering that we also see the captain
of the axiom struggling to walk in a
later scene it's a safe bet that nobody
on the ship is doing anything much more
strenuous than that the implication is
obviously that somewhere on the ship
there's a place where humans are grown
instead of born perhaps matrix style
just how the machines on the ship make
this happen we can only imagine wally is
largely an allegory and there are lots
of things we don't learn about in terms
of day-to-day life on the axiom but the
fact that we specifically get to see a
group of babies makes thoughts of basic
reproduction unavoidable and unavoidably
unsettling
wally strikes a carefully calculated
balance viewers need to identify with
the main robot so that they're not
thinking too hard about environmental
strife or the end of society it works
remarkably well except for how
cavalierly wally scavenges parts from
dead robot that look exactly like
himself first he pauses by the remains
of another wall-e unit to steal its
tread afterward when eve damages one of
his eyes he casually reveals that he has
an entire shelf of discarded wally parts
to choose from to replace it for adult
viewers this can result in a strange
cognitive dissonance in the movie's
emotional climax wally has been so badly
damaged that eve has to replace several
more parts and an internal circuit board
we're left in doubt for a moment that
wally even remembers her as he may be a
sort of undead frankenstein's monster of
other dead wallies with no memory
everything ultimately turns out okay but
only if you're willing to ignore wally's
robot cannibalism
there's so much that wally doesn't want
you to think too hard about that it's
hard to come away with a clear moral
lesson children's movies aren't
obligated to have one of course but they
almost always offer some sort of message
in the vein of just be yourself wally
presents a vague theme about the
difference between surviving and living
but it can be hard to really connect it
to anything particularly concrete
obviously we shouldn't let the planet
drown in garbage or the atmosphere
become toxic but what does wally suggest
we do to avoid it the damage from
climate change is so far reaching that
it's baffling to know where to start as
an individual to make a difference other
than a vague resolution to avoid excess
screen time and not be a passenger on
the proverbial axiom of the internet
there's not much that wally leaves you
with other than a warm feeling for cute
robots that's great and all but it won't
get all that excess carbon dioxide out
of the air
the technology depicted in wall-e was
all apparently made around the year 2100
when earth was becoming uninhabitable it
includes spaceships that are still
running perfectly after several hundred
years food replicators that feed the
entire ship's population to excess an
endless array of robots and hyperspace
technology that gets the axiom back to
earth in a matter of seconds so with all
this technology at its disposal how can
it be that the best plan that humanity's
corporate overlords could conceive of
was to leave a bunch of trash scooping
robots behind and try to wait the crisis
out on a cruise why not use the
hyperspace tech to try to find other
planets to colonize why aren't there
robots designed to scrub carbon from the
atmosphere why not shoot all the garbage
on earth into the sun perhaps there's an
intentionally cynical message and by and
large's plan to sell humans on a cruise
to distract them from the devastation
that their own consumerism has wrought
but you would think that finding a more
efficient solution would be good for the
company's bottom line as well
the thing that makes wally great in the
midst of all of its depressingly
realistic concerns about our present and
future is the fact that it barely
actually talks about those concerns at
all the first half is basically a silent
comedy as we watch our plucky hero fill
the time as best he can then it becomes
a breathless high-flying adventure when
eve shows up to shake him from his
routine the music score and beautiful
animation make wally a singular film
there's nothing else like it after
repeated viewings you'll probably start
to recognize every little mumble and
jittery noise that wally makes as an
extension of his personality
dialogue forms the backbone of most
movies it's how characters deliver key
exposition and reveal their motivations
directly or indirectly so by largely
foregoing spoken words wally achieves a
once in a century feat of storytelling
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]